[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 très belle année à
2022 c'est parti pour le premier
sommaire ce porte cette année 2022
football versailles continue son épopée
en coupe de france les versailles se
sont qualifiés pour les huitièmes de
finale de l'épreuve ils ont terrassé la
roche sur yon à domicile 4 à 0 plus
d'informations ce magazine rugby nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de léobard
et trois quarts polyvalent qui évolue
depuis un an stade français interview
insultant avec surugue iman prometteur
football coup de projecteur aujourd'hui
sur l'as poissy l'un des plus gros club
des yvelines avec une proue en équipe
première qui évolue en nationale 2 ce
sera notre module a découverte
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par la
magnifique qualification de versailles
en huitièmes de finale de la coupe de
france pour vous en parler nous avons
avec nous en plateau notre spécialiste
des résultats sportifs vinoy bixente
mérian santisteva bonsoir mon sens
michael alors vous commencé fort cette
année 2022 vous étiez sur place racontez
nous oui c'était un seizième historique
pour une qualification historique du fc
versailles qui jouait son destin face à
la roche vendée un club de nationale 3
soit une division dessous les
versaillais ont su faire respecter la
hiérarchie une victoire nette et sans
bavure 4 à 0 devant les 2000 spectateurs
du stade mont boron youssef chebbi
l'entraîneur du club nous explique
comment s'est préparé la rencontre donc
l'affût il a fallu que les jours se
mettre dans une bulle c'est ce qu'ils
ont très bien fait et au fur et à mesure
de la rencontre notamment cette peinture
les éléments étaient en notre faveur ben
être porté par le public ça donne de la
force de l'énergie la confiance c'est ce
qui s'est passé un match donc bien
embarquée car dès la 12e minute
versailles mène 2 à 0 un doublé de son
attaquant christopher iba y premier but
de la tête sur un coup franc bien
senties et quatre minutes plus tard une
nouvelle tête plongeante cette fois on
lui a demandé ce que ça faisait
d'inscrire un doublé dans un match
importantissime voici sa réaction ça
fait toujours plaisir ça fait toujours
plaisir après voilà aujourd'hui ce qui
prime c'est le collectif honnêtement
c'est notre force de culte du
championnat
pour le monde par les résultats on n'a
pas beaucoup dans cette défaite qu'une
seule avec quelques nuls mais beaucoup
de victoires voilà aujourd'hui merci les
coéquipiers de mettre dans les
meilleures dispositions et moi j'essaie
de faire le taf on peut tout simplement
versailles qui aurait pu se faire peur à
la 19e minute puisque son gardien dan
delaunay provoque un penalty mais se
rattrape en plongeant du bon côté et en
arrêtant la tentative vendéenne c'est le
tournant du match mais chanter pour moi
oui mickaël puisqu'on l'a senti dans le
stade c'était comme un symbole que tout
réussir et aux versaillais ce jour là
est la preuve cinq minutes plus tard
avec un petit bijou du latéral gauche
makan traoré une reprise de volée de 20
mètres dans le petit filet opposé si
vous avez une minute mickaël je vous
conseille de chercher le but sur les
réseaux sociaux il est facile à trouver
ça vaut le détour et donc pour
compliquer la donne vraiment un réflexe
de data qu'on va dire et pour compléter
donc l'addition le défenseur walid you
free est allé de son but également pour
sceller le score dès la mi temps 4 à 0
alors tout ça c'était en première
période mais que s'est il passé au
retour des vestiaires à vrai dire plus
grand chose si je ne puis dire on a eu
donc la facette offensives en première
et en deuxième c'était la symbolique
maîtrise défensive de versailles
l'équipe a su gérer les tentatives
d'assaut de la roche qui ne le saura
jamais vraiment inquiété hormis
peut-être un poteau aux alentours de la
80e minute de jeu écoutez d'ailleurs un
des hommes forts de cette solidité
défensive
le jeune défenseur et capitaine de 22
ans maël durant de jeu vignes et c'est
certainement parce que ça fait déjà
quatre ans que je suis là enseignants
on n'est que le huitième de finale avec
l'aide de cette équipe avec beaucoup
joueur de
on s'est rencontré il ya pas longtemps
il ya six mois c
est comme vous le disiez c'est une
qualification historique pour le club
oui puisque un petit rappel du palmarès
dans cette coupe de france versailles
avait déjà connu un 16e de finale mais
il faut remonter en 1947 et ce n'était
pas passé une défaite 4 buts 1 contre le
fc gueugnon et depuis on a eu en 2009
une victoire notable contre dijon qui
évolué en ligue 2 mais suivie d'une
défaite en 32e de finale contre l'as
beauvais pour le tirage du prochain tour
c'est demain soir pour youssef chibi
l'entraîneur peu importe l'adversaire
mais du côté du joueur on a senti quand
même une certaine motivation de se
frotter aux plus gros le paris saint
germain l'olympique de marseille monaco
par exemple quoi qu'il en soit nous on
prend rendez vous le 29 ou le 30 janvier
prochain pour un match qui sera quoi
qu'il arrive dans les mémoires du club
merci à bixente pour toutes ces
précisions j'espère que vous reviendrez
pour une qualification de versailles en
quarts de finale j'essaie du mois on va
renverser la vapeur 18 mois un veau de
boxe à présent est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour tony yoka le boxeur originaire de
chanteloup les vignes ne boxera
finalement pas le 15 janvier prochain
l'accord arena de paris bercy contre le
congolais martin bacot l'est le combat a
été reporté à cause de la crise
sanitaire et de la mise en place d'une
jauge de 2000 spectateurs pour le sport
en intérieur ce que mettait en question
l'équilibré financier de l'événement
tony hawk eye estime avoir pris un petit
coup au moral ils affirment être prêts à
combattre les plus grands il a
d'ailleurs lancé un défi à anthony
joshua l'un des meilleurs boxeurs de la
planète en affirmant qu' poule vais le
boxer à tous les jours pour l'instant
l'intéressé n'a pas encore répondu
toujours au chapitre annulation ce
devait être une première dans les
yvelines miss et mister fitness france
prévue au sd cs center de maurepas fin
décembre a été reportée au samedi à 26
février la raison des cas de co vite ont
été déclarés la compétition doit réunir
20 sportives venues de toute la france
ces derniers doivent s'affronter sur des
exercices pratiqués en salle de sport
comme des pompes des tractions ou encore
des squats on va maintenant parler à
rugby nous suivons régulièrement son
évolution sur tv 78 le rugbyman illinois
à léo a barré poursuit sa progression
stade français il a joué dix matches
depuis le début de la saison dernière en
date ce samedi 1er janvier
pour débuter la phase retour face à
perpignan notre journaliste nicolas
attendre il a rencontré juste avant noël
regardez nous sommes au stade jean bouin
l'antre du stade français paris avec le
versailles et les au bar et bonjour les
eaux bonjour alors du coup un bon début
de saison puisque je rappelle un tué
arrière polyvalent au stade français
paris tu à 19 ans tu as joué neuf
matches depuis le début de cette saison
au sur 12 quel bilan tu fais de ce début
de saison du coup bah du coup plutôt
positif beaucoup de confiance aussi
personnelles données par le staff un
début de saison un peu compliqué pour
nos supporters parce que on n'a pas lu
pas mal de défaites et abc dont beaucoup
plus positif pour moi pour tous des
saisons où j'ai pu enchaîner avec les
pros ouais t'as joué énormément de
minutes finalement deux joueurs c'est ça
a énormément de minutes de jeu puis
surtout une continuité c'est ce que j'ai
réussi à enchaîner cinq matches
d'affilée à chaque fois après ils m'ont
laissé au repos 24 et c'était plutôt
c'était plutôt c'est plutôt intéressant
pour moi d'évoluer avec les grands on va
revenir sur deux faits de jeu le premier
d'abord à perpignan une pénalité décisif
pour cette victoire à aimé giral d'un
oui c'est ça fait très plaisir de cette
pénalité c'est sûr beaucoup de fierté de
de la mettre surtout pour ce club
pour qu'ils veulent enfin simple une
porte dans le coeur et surtout fait ces
moments là c'est je viens de prendre un
coup et je me retourne directement
vergonzeanne brillamment je peux la
prendre je peux l'apprendre lui je pense
qu'il n'est pas trop chaud pour que je
la prenne et au final c'est plutôt bien
passé et puis voilà je rappelle que tu
as dix neuf ans comment gères justement
ce genre de situation où la pression
doit être énorme quand même je pense ont
la pression sur le match on l'a enfin
moi les évacuer ses vents ont joué ou
jouent le jeu c'est on joue au rugby
elle parle dans une autre bulle aussi
je sais que après quand j'ai regardé le
match il y avait beaucoup d'ambiance
mais à aimé giral mais pour le match et
on est dans notre bulle donc ça va
beaucoup jouer
parce qu'en tant que buteur faut
vraiment se mettre dans sa bulle l'autre
fait de jeu c'est un match face à
clermont pareil vous êtes devant et là
les clermontois vont pour inscrire un
essai finalement dernier défenseur tu
arrives qui arrive à retenir et ne pas
faire que clermont marc cet essai qui
aurait pu les faire gagner quoi surtout
qu'il n'a pas contrôlé à bâle avant
qu'il n'apprenne pas moi qu'il est trop
j'étais un peu gêné mais je pense que
voilà
là sur ce match là si plutôt faut plutôt
noté pas cette action mais plus l'équipe
où on a fait un gros gros match mais
mais voilà oui pareil ça m'a fait
plaisir de la entre guillemets sauver
l'équipe mais en soit je pense qu'il a
vraiment fait tomber la balle avant que
je plaque alors je disais au début tu
arrière polyvalent tu joues à la fois
demi d'ouverture centre arrière comment
tu gères tout ça justement cette
polyvalence je gère enfin de façon
plutôt positif parce que c'est que du
bonus pour moi c'est que du plus de
pouvoir toucher à plusieurs postes
d'être 15 d'être 12 d'être dit voilà je
sais c'est vraiment top en plus ils me
font vraiment confiance le staff sur
chacun des postes donc c'est vraiment
une plus value pour moi et pour fort
surtout les années à venir me voir
plusieurs postes en poche c'est plutôt
bien on le connaît sur les antennes de
télé 78 vient de versailles est-ce que
tu déjà à versailles au rcv autres clubs
de versailles tu tu avais cette
polyvalence cela en juniors en cadets
c'est un massif quand j'étais à verser
c'est à l'école de rugby on n'a pas trop
de poste j'étais plus destiné à jouer je
voulais 10 ou 12 et puis après on a six
as et continuelle soit en france a
continué avec les deux postes et puis
voilà c'est ça a continué sur les années
à massy et puis maintenant c'est aux
français alors au stade français et y
est depuis un an maintenant tu as
signant l est et 2020
tu nous disais l'année dernière quand on
était venu te voir que c'était le club
de ton coeur un an après ça va renforcer
l'attachement à ce club oui il a été
rattaché déjà comme j'avais dit la
dernière c'est un club qui est assez
historique un parcours assez atypique
par rapport aux autres clubs et
et puis c'est surtout le club de la
capitale enfin voilà c'est ça a été
toujours j'ai grandi dans la région
parisienne donc le stade français pour
moi c'est un gros club et ça restera
hétu a prolongé son contrat en octobre
dernier jusqu'en 2025 et c'était un
choix parce que la cause de cet
attachement attachement et puis surtout
si le projet projets qui m'intéressent
beaucoup de faire jouer je presse le
maximum de jeunes de les imprégner
surtout de c'est surtout des jeunes qui
sont issus de la formation de la
formation parisienne enfin de massy ou
des alentours je pense à leicester et
tiens j adele bouillie ou m6 cookies un
peu plusieurs voix lasse et des joueurs
qui sont passés par par la région
ile-de-france et du coup c'est le projet
aussi du club ce soit qui ait un lien
avec l'île de france enfin la région ile
de france c'est pour ça aussi qu'il ya
un partenariat avec avec massy alors ton
engagement et pour le stade français
mais ton engagement il est aussi pour
l'équipe de france l'équipe de france
moins de 20 ans quels sont tes objectifs
justement avec l'équipe de france moins
de 20 ans sachant que tu as quatre
sélections déjà avec eux cette équipe
ouais c'est ça qu'a deux sélections la
dernière au mois deux mois de juin pour
le ton à destination les objectifs sont
clairs c'est déjà de participer et puis
après le gagner voilà c'est de gagner la
dernière on était en avait perdu contre
les anglais en entrée de tournoi où ça
nous avait un peu bousculé et on avait
super bien réagi ensuite
contre l'italie un peu timidement mais
surtout contre le pays de galles
l'écossé ensuite l'irlande mais voilà je
pense que cette année c'est une nouvelle
année avec des nouveaux joueurs et il
faut je pense aller chercher chercher ce
tournoi est aussi bon là je crois que la
coupe du monde est annulé mais il ya des
espèces de tournoi à la fin de la fin du
mois de juin donc faire de plus de
sections possible et clément de vin et
gagner plus possible quand tu vois les
grands le quinze de france les résultats
tu as déjà le quinze de france en tête
même si tu as encore 19 ans c'est encore
trop je pense encore trop jeune pour y
penser oui c'est sûr ça rêve pour chaque
jour qui joue sur le terrain mais
vraiment là mon objectif est déjà joué
avec l'équipe première du stade
bassement et participer avec les moins
de 20 mais c'est surtout vrai quand on
voit les résultats en équipe de france
leur dernière victoire face aux
all-blacks et c'est assez incroyable et
c'est aussi grâce je pense la formation
qui acquit à qui a dans tous les clubs
de top 14 donc
faux dans le compte de la tête mais pour
l'instant on vise on vise plus - moins
de 20 à temps et la pluie qui première
un dernier mot les eaux qu'est-ce qu'on
peut te souhaiter pour l'année 2022 ben
maximum de matches en pro et puis gagner
surtout gagner et puis la santé surtout
la santé merci de mai au bar et arrière
polyvalent du stade français paris issue
de la formation versaillaise
s'il est au bar est resté sérieux
pendant les fêtes ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde en tout cas pas moi les
français prennent en moyenne 1,5 kg
pendant cette période pour les perdre
rapidement quoi de mieux que l'activité
physique un coach sportif versailles et
vous livre ses conseils pour détoxifier
votre corps un reportage de grégory
canal et
33% des français l'inscrivent comme
première bonne résolution pour 2022
faire du sport plus régulièrement un
moyen efficace pour détoxifier son corps
après l'abondance des repas de fête
l'activité physique va vous aider à vous
sentir mieux que je le conseillais ça va
être des exercices qui vont être très
simple ça va être commencer par des
exercices cardio donc ça est déjà dans
un premier temps se mettre en marche si
on voit qu'on n'a pas assez de résultats
a pas assez d'intensité on va y aller
progressivement sur de la course pour
avoir l'envié d'aller plus loin dans son
entraînement
ajoutez ensuite du renforcement
musculaire le traditionnel gainage en
veillant à garder une bonne posture sans
lever les fesses trop des pompes pour
les plus courageux ou encore les
célèbres squatte une flexion des jambes
très efficace pour brûler la graisse des
exercices simples et fonctionnelle en
ajoutant au fil des semaines intensité
et difficultés on va commencer avec deux
à trois fois par semaine à l'idée c'est
de prendre goût au sport goût à
l'activité physique et dès qu'on a pris
goût on peut augmenter la fréquence en y
ajoutant divers disciplines un toujours
varié ses entraînements pour pas habitué
son corps à un type d'effort un maître
mot la progressivité quand le corps
n'est pas habitué à l'effort mieux vaut
commencer en douceur en as tu ça va être
deux il y aller progressivement c'est
par exemple sur la course on l'a on
entend souvent faut courir une heure 45
minutes pour ça soit efficace moi je
vais vous conseiller de courir cinq
minutes ça va vous donner confiance en
vous et par la suite on termine sur de
la marche donc vous allez avoir une
sorties en extérieur d'une heure par
exemple avec un peu de course et la fois
d'après on va augmenter on va passer sur
dix minutes 15 minutes et ainsi de suite
une détox sportive a pratiqué chez vous
ou en salle ce studio a ouvert depuis
avril dernier dans le centre-ville de
versailles il propose des séances avec
les conseils d'un coach sportif qui peut
venir également à domicile compter entre
30 et 60 euros le cours au travail
on passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur de la semaine aujourd'hui tv
78 est allé du côté de poissy pour
rencontrer le club de football de l'as
poissy un club historique avec des
ambitions dans le championnat de
nationale 2 regardez
aujourd'hui pour commencer à 2022 tv 78
sur les terrains de foot pour découvrir
le club de poissy
[Musique]
alors le président olivier à ces visites
n'a pas pu venir aujourd'hui sur cette
session d'entraînement mais il avec nous
via vision alors olivier ses musiques
quelle est l'histoire de ce club
l'histoire avant mon arrivée donc cela
fait maintenant cinq ans c'est vrai que
c'était un club
qui a été fondée il ya très très
longtemps
il a eu la chance de jouer en division 2
à l'époque avec des noms comme gérard
soler j'ai c'est que ça toujours été un
club très important dans les yvelines
pour le reste bas que te dire d'autre
c'est une ville très sportive comme vous
le savez tous dans les yvelines
indépendamment du football mais pour
l'as poissy quand j'ai repris les rênes
du club il ya maintenant cinq ans de
mémoire ben c'est un club qui était déjà
en nationale 2 avec son histoire et
que dire de ce club bien structuré
évidemment par un club professionnel on
le sait très bien pour la nationale 2
qui est toujours en championnat hybride
et est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
le club grandit d'année en année alors
ça
je vais avoir un peu d'humilité parce
que c'est pas évident de répondre à ces
questions là je pense que
par rapport à au travail que j'ai essayé
de réaliser ce qui m'importe c'est de
faire des actions concernant l'équipe
première en cinq ans bon il ya eu comme
idée évidemment nous avons toujours
réussi à nous maintenir
ce que je sais quand j'ai repris le club
c'est qu'il y avait à l'époque des
subventions beaucoup plus importante et
que le club avait un budget
comment expliquer les choses mais je ne
veux évidemment offusquer personne mais
mais c'est vrai que quand je suis arrivé
d'année en année les subventions ont été
baissés même si je sais que monsieur
karl olive qui je m'entends d'ailleurs
très bien a toujours fait les efforts
nécessaires peut-être qu'il y avait une
gabegie à l'époque un mais on
m'annonçait des sept cent mille euros
de subventions pour le club on est à peu
près à 275 mille aujourd'hui
grandir oui par rapport à toutes les
actions qui ont été menées ce que j'ai
essayé de mener que mes équipes
d'ailleurs parce que je suis pas seul
dans un club bien évidemment est ce que
vous allez sentiment que vous avez les
infrastructures pour que le club
progresse olive et ses musiques les
infrastructures très honnêtement on a
des terrains d'entraînement de qualité
on a deux sites notre terrain d'honneur
qui est un très beau terrain
un terrain d'entraînement pour l'équipe
première à ces terrains pour les équipes
de jeunes évidemment on voudrait
toujours un peu plus il est difficile
parfois de refuser des jeunes parce que
au niveau des plannings c'est assez
compliqué mais on a les infrastructures
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour pour être
en nationale 2 olivier ses musiques vous
avez eu de nombreux coachs sous votre
présidence laurent fournier a quitté le
club en novembre 2020 il a été remplacé
par ouali dachau qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce coach c'est un choix par
rapport à sa connaissance ce qu'ils
avaient apportés à viry châtillon
il a fait quoi quand même monter
l'équipe trois fois donc je pense qu'il
avait toutes les qualités nécessaires
pour emmener ce groupe on peut
aujourd'hui on travaille ensemble depuis
maintenant six mois on a fait un très
très bon début de saison il a repris
très tôt il est très rigoureux et comme
j'ai dis parfois aux gens avec lequel je
peux discuter de sa position il a les
clés du camion c'est à dire je suis
propriétaire du camion moi qui suis dans
la logistique et le transport mais il a
les clés du camion il a choisi ses
joueurs donc je laisse travailler je
pense vraiment très sereinement avec son
staff qui la choisit d'ailleurs 2022 à
votre avis est-ce que c'est une année
qui va réussir à poissy ou 2022 ça va
être une autre page qui va s'ouvrir moi
je souhaite effectivement déjà qu'on se
maintienne parce qu en toute humilité je
pense qu'on n'a pas les moyens d'aller
beaucoup plus haut
et puis derrière oui je pense que ça
peut être une belle saison
[Musique]
je suis maintenant avec le coach walid
alors walid quel est l'objectif de
poissy cette saison l'objectif toujours
été le maintien
donc on va essayer de se maintenir le
plus rapidement possible et comment fait
justement pour ce matin on sait que ce
championnat de nationale 2 est un
championnat quand même assez compliqué
comment on fait pour se maintenir
je faisais les solutions les solutions
c'est de continuer à jouer comme ans
comme on joue c'est à dire
être solides collectivement voir la
position du ballon et c'est par contre
d'être plus efficace devant le but tout
simplement et vous le travail à
l'entraînement j'imagine fait que ça est
par exemple là pour pour un championnat
comme celui là quels sont les quelles
sont les armes qu'il faut avoir à votre
avis pour réussir à aller plus haut
commettre le moins d'erreurs possible
déjà c'est déjà parce qu'on joue contre
beaucoup d'équipés qui attendent les
erreurs de l'adversaire c'est sûr c'est
à dire la conque on concède beaucoup
d'occasions vous êtes actuellement dans
le milieu de classement de cette
nationale 2 beaucoup d'équipés que vous
avez affronté nous ont dit après le
match que vous aviez un style de jeu qui
les avait en bts que vous avez ce
sentiment là
ouais mais ça fait partie ça a toujours
fait partie de mes plans
alors nous on n'a pas d'énormes budgets
comme versailles comme charte ou autre
donc je voulais qu'on soit une équipe
embêtante justement
donc
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai ramené
quelques joueurs qui connaissent le
niveau et et voilà plutôt des bons
joueurs donc
vous appuyez sur qui justement dans
cette équipe on sait qu'il ya un joueur
un peu un peu vedette encore clément
chantôme qui qui a joué au psg sur quel
autre jour vous vous appuyer oui
forcément s'appuie sur son expérience de
clémence à
ccc ce serait une erreur de ne pas
s'appuyer sur des relais sur lui mais
aussi sur voilà sur d'autres joueurs
comme lassana conté qui est qui et rien
une âme aussi d'être le capitaine donc
donc voilà qui est plutôt qui connaît
très bien le niveau et qui est plutôt
tout plutôt quelqu'un de réfléchi donc
non quoi clément chantôme justian casque
et qu'est ce qu'il apporte sur le
terrain est ce que vous sentez qu'il
qu'il a joué au niveau qu'ils apportent
ce petit plus qui permet à poissy des
fois de se surpasser match un peu tendu
wow forcément l'enseignement c'est mon
joueur le plus régulier déjà qui restait
des piles depuis la préparation il
restait un niveau très intéressant et il
répète ces matches là donc c'est la
différence qu'il ya entre lui et les
autres joueurs après forcément c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'avoir un clément
chantôme avec avec soi que le contre
donc
comment vous définiriez comme coach vous
êtes plutôt un coach défensif offensif
moi je cherche plutôt l'equilibre de mon
équipe à vous tous d'être offensifs ou
défensifs cherche plutôt d'avoir un
certain équilibre parce que je pars du
principe que ce qui est le plus
important c'est la récupération du
ballon et ensuite forcément
c'est j'aime bien avoir la pression du
ballon et j'aimerais essayer de produire
du jeu plutôt que jouer le jeu direct
donc voilà après c'est ma philosophie
mais mais ce qui ce qui compte à la fin
c'est l'efficacité de deux manières dans
les deux surfaces merci walid et je vous
laisse retourner à l'entraînement
je suis maintenant avec deux joueurs de
poissy à lassana et clément alors
clément pourquoi vous avez choisi pau si
c'est tout simple c'est parce que
j'arrêtais ma carrière pro après le mon
passage au red star j'avais besoin de
revenir sur paris et puis j'habite juste
à côté donc c'était aussi simple que ça
et puis aussi à l'époque avait laurent
fournier et le président conte un peu
fait le forcing pour que je reprenne
j'avais arrêté six mois je la vente est
d'arrêter complètement puis je retrouve
un peu de un peu de plaisir un peu lent
vidéo de côtoyer un groupe du coup ça ça
me fait du bien et puis d'être à côté
voilà et vous ont convaincu ouais ouais
si j'attendais côté financier c'était
pas ça peco non c'est aussi parce que
c'est la passion qui est qui reprend le
dessus et puis moi j'étais habitué
depuis que j'ai l'âge de 12 ans des
tranchantes m'entraîne tous les jours et
le fait d'arrêter pendant six mois
j'étais à ces jeunes du coup l'envié est
revenue là c'est là pour toi c'est quoi
du coup voici qu'est ce que pourquoi tu
as rejoint ce club bah moi déjà je suis
un enfant de la maison parisienne on va
dire chanter deux saisons posco vidal
entente ou à un peu plus compliqué et on
m'a proposé un projet ici qui était qui
était intéressant on vous laisse le club
voulait se relancer du coup j'ai accepté
j'ai accepté le projet qu'est ce que
vous pensez des structures du club
justement ça ça vous aide à vous
épanouir c'est vrai que dans la région
n'y a pas beaucoup de clubs sont cons
ces structures là on peut s'entraîner
sur terrain herbe toute la semaine donc
ouais ça facilite pour pour travailler
pour pour être sonné l'ambiance
familiale on parle beaucoup d'ambiance
familiale ici à poissy la scène est ce
que tu leur sans toi bah ouais c'est
clair c'est con quand il a parlé quand
on n'a pas les des moyens comme certains
clubs on est obligé de s'accrocher à
certaines valeurs et c'est vrai que
c'est une des valeurs de ce club là
donc ouais c'est clair qu'on ressent
dans tous les étages du club familial
l'ambiance c'est sarah clément qu'est ce
que vous appelez parts familiales c'est
ça qu'il faut savoir
non après ici c'est ici en quand même
avant et des choses qui sont distincts
que c'est là une de l'équipe fanion du
du club et puis après tout les autres
équipes donc je pense que il ya un bon
esprit dans ce club mais je pense que
vous pourrez mieux faire pour avoir une
cohésion entre l'équipe fanion et le
reste du club comment ça se passe avec
le coach wade assure qui a rêvé depuis
un an ici les résultats parlent quand
même plutôt pour lui le club a l'air de
taux remonter
comme je pense à l'entendre ici ça a été
compliqué avec le co vide n'a pas été
évident de gérer on a eu de la chance on
va pas se mentir et avec l'arrêt de la
saison parce qu'on était très mal parti
là ça va mieux après
60 en dents de scie en ce moment on
aurait pu mieux faire parce que on a une
équipe qui joue très bien cette année
ont je pense que les résultats au fait
même pas de classement même si c'est
mieux cette année on aurait pu être
encore plus haut vous avez fait
également un neuvième tour à 8e tour de
coupe de france ouais c'est un peu une
déception surtout qu'on perd contre le
voisin versailles on avait le match va
dire le match en main on assez creux
procuré beaucoup d'occasions on aurait
pu essayer de passer ça aurait été une
belle aventure pour le club mais bon
c'est déjà pas mal par rapport aux
années précédentes
clément l'a dit cette année ça joue bien
au foot ici à poissy bah c'est clair
j'ai moi j'étais pas là les saisons
précédentes mais c'est clair qu'on
produit du beau football maintenant on
peut pas s'arrêter qu'à ça parce que les
résultats comme et clément sont en dents
de scie on a une place qui reflète pas
notre qualité de jeu donc
voilà à choisir entre le jeu et les
points bas des fois faut plutôt prendre
des points mais on va essayer d'allier
les deux oui la shoah dit que vous étiez
les deux piliers de cette équipe clément
comment comment tout leur sens pilier
dans quel sens par rapport à la jour
avoir la qualité enfin à part la qualité
à vendre non après ça c'est normal on a
on a plus d'expérience que que d'autres
donc cesser c'est important d'avoir sur
le terrain des guides pour pouvoir que
l'équipe se comporte à fait bien pendant
le match et transcrire ce que ce que le
coach veut sur le terrain même chose
ouais c'est ça on va dire mon pilier
clément on va dire que c'est plus le
piller dans la qualité technique moi ça
va être dans la boîte mois effet de
replacer les gars mais au caractère
apparemment chez ou lassana non non non
il ya des conseils il faut les respecter
donc on essaye déjà avec dernière
question 2022 cowboys cette année ici à
poissy je pensais quelque chose à faire
il faut qu'on continue de garder cette
maîtrise qu'on a au fur et à mesure des
matches par contre il faut convertir sa
en point et si on ne le fait je pense
qu'on peut on peut être tranquille de
faire une saison tranquille et pourquoi
pas accrocher quelque chose en fin de
saison comme choses clairement ouais bah
il faut soit son nom n'a pas d'objectif
précis à part de se maintenir donc si on
peut essayer de viser autre chose le
haut du tableau et faire plaisir
pourquoi pas vous n'êtes pas loin du top
5 bah ouais c'est très serré après faut
faire attention c'est si on achète du
mossad et de regarder vers le bas aussi
parce que ça rassure monde huit
forcément quand tu prends pas de point
phare moment que derrière donc essayé
comme dit l'abbé de gagner des matches
pour pouvoir jouer quelque chose et
faire une fin de saison assez tranquille
et pouvoir préparer l'année préfet
prochaine vous l'aurez compris le club
de poissy a d'énormes ambitions pour
2022 et pourquoi pas une place dans le
top 5 en fin de saison en nationale 2
c'est la fin cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi encore une très belle
année sur tv 78
[Musique]